thank you very much I'm like to discuss
some ideas that I've been working on ur
thinking about with jon cole at Harvard
Business School dan bjerke green who's
uh was a grad student in economics but
as and has a tech background is now at
Brown University rise up abrogastes a
student at the Kennedy School PhD threw
in there and I was Jen who just
completed an MBA we on several of us in
this team had been involved in studies
of Agricultural Extension and
particularly mobile phone Agricultural
Extension and the academic work that we
had done on this both God your God got
us excited about the potential so I
wanted to describe a little bit about
why and and about a possible vision for
a way forward so we're Sean Cole and I
are both I development economists and as
are many of the other people on this
team and the productivity of many
smallholder farms in the developing
world seems to be below product below
potential so I actually an old topic in
development economics and arguably we've
come full circle you know there was an
idea that small holder farmers were not
producing to their potential than a
reaction to that an idea that they were
maximally efficient taking advantage of
all opportunities and I think now
there's an increasing recognition that
not everybody in any industry is ever
fully at the maximum productivity
frontier that's not true for 44
industries in the United States and it's
not true in developing countries either
of course if you're if farmers aren't
all automatically at the frontier of
productivity that suggests that there
might be potential for agricultural
extension and in fact obviously
governments and uh and and others have
been investing in agricultural extension
for a long time but for most farmers in
the developing world there's very
limited sources of agricultural
extension or maybe more broadly I
proflow information so government
extension services are very often quite
broken so let me talk about you know
several dimensions of that first
organizationally there's just you
government bureaucracies don't always
function perfectly and you know that
that might be particularly true in a lot
of developing countries and the fact is
a lot of extension agents rarely make it
to the field partly because they don't
have fuel for their motorcycles partly
because they have very limited
accountability um there's also spatial
constraints so farmers are dispersed and
while there may be cases like we heard
of where wheat is just wheat there are
also lots of cases where there's lots of
fine variation in soil composition in
microclimate and you really need to
tailor Agricultural Extension advice to
fairly precise areas but these massive
Agricultural Extension services often
give much coarser messages with the
recommendation for your entire region of
a country for example there temporarily
constrained so very farmers most farmers
don't see Agricultural Extension agents
they're certainly not going to see our
grelot extension agents frequently but
one of the things we've learned from
behavioral economics is that timely
information makes a difference if it's
now time to to weed and you've got a
particular pastor you need advice on
that you know getting that advice nine
months or there before that pest is
there may not be that useful there's
temporal ah so that's a temporal of
constraint so all of these all of these
things mean that there's actually quite
wide consensus that a lot of Public
Agricultural Extension services are
organized on traditional lines which
governments are spending a lot of money
on are not necessarily that effective
where do farmers get information well
one big place they get information from
is from input dealers of course they
have a financial interest in sign
particular products I don't know how
much Shawn Cole who I understand
presented earlier today was able to
cover this but there are really terrible
cases are in joint and joint work with
on
Fernando and Sean they found you know
agar dealers were really promoting very
dangerous pesticides that were totally
unnecessary when there were cheaper safe
alternatives available for example in
their in their work in India so there's
been a movement towards saying we'll
look the public system isn't working why
don't we have private agricultural
extension and the farmers will just pay
the private Agricultural Extension
Service for their for their advice there
may be some cases in which that can work
i don't want to totally write it off but
that's also subject to some pretty
severe problems so to market failures
are highlight in particular first
information is very different than many
other goods if you sell information to
me you may not get the full benefit of
that because I can pass that information
on to neighbors and the person producing
the information or selling the
information may not get the full value
and we see something like this and all
the problems of say the the the music
industry you know people are sharing the
music and they can't appropriate the
full value of it same thing can happen
with agricultural advice but another
issue that's an even deeper issue as I
can listen to music and decide whether I
like it if I'm a farmer and an extension
agent is coming to me and telling me
something how do I know that that advice
is worth paying for especially if you
know you could it's hard to learn from a
single season often so this certainly
inhibits the growth of private
agricultural extension on a
subscription-based model where the
farmer on a case-by-case basis is paying
for it also just practically you know
these farmers have very little money
there's huge customer acquisition costs
it's not a it's probably not really a
scalable you know there's some I'm sure
there's some niche markets where this
will work but that's probably not going
to transform agricultural productivity
and developing countries so our belief
is that there's a number of
technological changes that are really
increasing the scope for agricultural
extension so it's a range of them
including new sensors that can pick up
soil composition iria that can you know
whether information so you know how much
soil moisture there is there's some very
interesting things going on
and really developed country agriculture
is starting to be transformed by what's
called precision agriculture that uses a
vast amount of this data on one key
technological change in the developing
world is the rapid spread of the mobile
phone and we think that this offers an
opportunity to deliver at least some
form of information I don't want to say
it completely replaces human beings it
could complement it or or there it's
necessarily as good as what you could
get an ideal situation with human beings
but a lot of information could be
delivered could be tailored to specific
to the spatial location of farmers to be
delivered at the time of year when
farmers need that information at very
low marginal cost so in what would we
have in mind well obviously I discussed
the agro climatic conditions you could
tailor recommendations to a very
particular region with mobile phones
things like soil chemistry local weather
forecasts what past outbreaks there are
but you could go beyond that so there's
been some efforts to tailor to provide
sir very simple market information on
prices to farmers those have a mixed
record but I think you can go much
beyond that you could say for example
you know this type of fertilizer might
work for you and the closest dealer to
you that has that is in this town and
it's the shop you could on you could do
things like demand-supply aggregation
and sales leads so for example if you
knew that a bunch of farmers had their
tomatoes ready you might provide that
information to a dealer who then might
say hey I'm going to take a truck out to
that area and pick those things up you
could um very importantly if you're
dealing in the developed world where
farmers are many farmers are highly
educated they've got a lot of capital
available um am i running out of time
all I give us okay I better vastly speed
up sorry um you could tell this
departments their their their land
available the labor availability even
their risk preferences so you could tell
information very well now now what's
more you could learn over time as
technology firms do you could constantly
be running experiments what's the best
way to deliver information the farmers
find most valuable they react
you could get reports back from farmers
on how the advice you've been given how
did that work out in practice for them
and then much like Netflix so Netflix
will say I will tell Netflix did I like
a movie because I know that means
Netflix is going to be able to use its
algorithm to predict what other movies
are like similarly if I tell Netflix
this fertilizer didn't work out for me
that can allow that can allow this an
entity that was doing this to provide
better information but could also
improve its algorithm and give better
recommendations to other farmers with
similar characteristics and so you could
you could constantly you could have a
dynamic learning system and improve the
quality of this type of system over time
okay what's more what could the impact
of this bit well in in the work that
Sean's done in with co-authors in India
some of the work that I've been involved
in in Kenya found and some other work
suggests that you can get significant
increases in agricultural productivity
on the order of ten percent you could
also of climate benefits because you
could help people adapt to climate
change and you could perhaps a graduate
student named Islam has done incredible
work showing that you can reduce
fertilizer use and increase output in
Bangladesh so suggestion environmental
benefits I suggest I you know there may
be other benefits to this data beyond
just better information for farmers I
don't think this could work by solving
this to farmers I think that's a pipe
dream however there are other ways you
could finance somethin like this so
contract farming organizations trigger
companies dairy cooperatives they make
they want X often want extra supply it
may be worth it to them these things are
very cheap to deliver even though
they're only making you know a certain
margin on increased output they may be
willing to pay for the services for
there for there are farmers on and get
make a profit from it I mean some of our
work suggests that preliminary works of
justice would be profitable obviously
governments or international
organizations or large foundations on
could help do this for staple crops so
we think that there are other possible
sources of revenue you could think about
advertising over time much the way of
Facebook would or Google would do this
you could think about tacos paying for
this to the actual economic cost if you
do it in off-peak hours are incredibly
small especially with data costs coming
down smartphones becoming more available
this could be a way this could be
something that a Google or Facebook
that's very interested in expanding
internet access could decide they want
to sponsor to help encourage people to
sign up to the internet so we think
there's a lot of potential for this and
you know we're just starting to think
about this but we'd love in the break
I'd love to get people's reactions or
ideas to this idea thanks very much